[Music]
for the first time in history NASA wants
to hand off routine International Space
Station resupply missions to private
companies though there's way more at
stake than just food and equipment
deliveries these space taxi companies
hope to transport astronauts soon and
after that
tourists so here's the situation
these four american companies including
Elon Musk's SpaceX are building
spacecraft to ferry nasa supplies or
astronauts to space and we have liftoff
of space X Falcon 9 rocket and dragon to
make space tourism realistic the price
of these trips needs to come down
space entrepreneurs are counting on two
words to cut costs reusable rockets
until now
booster rockets simply burned up upon
re-entering Earth's atmosphere musk says
creating booster rockets that real and
instead could reduce the cost of a trip
a hundredfold in 2015 both Blue Origin
and SpaceX successfully landed Rockets
touchdown engines ballon Musk's reaction
welcome back baby
since then SpaceX has now recovered
eight rockets in total three by land and
five by sea now here's the argument
since the space shuttle program ended in
2011 nASA has been focused on Mars and a
farther reaches of space
that leaves Russia's SIU's spacecraft as
NASA's only option for sending
astronauts into orbit rides that cost
around 70 million dollars per seat some
argue that private competition will
bring down the price and with it the
cost of space exploration
but there are very real safety concerns
Virgin Galactic spaceship 2 designed to
haul tourists to the edge of space
crashed on a test flight in October 2014
killing a pilot but for a commercial
company in addition to being a tragedy
the crash with passengers on board could
end space tourism altogether for now
NASA's only option seems to be Russia
you